michael smith back here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
good i'm just cracking up because y'all
just get right to the good part right
y'all just got bent y'all got uh ben
simmons going to portland for damn i
love it well i mean after the matter no
i i'll be honest with you michael y'all
is doing a lot of heavy lifting there's
there's one uh there's one on the rich
eisen show that thinks that and that's
t.j jefferson to my right hey i got it i
got to put it out there in the universe
michael you know if i want it to happen
i got to you know
kind of speak it
into existence as they say if that's
gonna work though
what do you think michael yeah that's
fascinating we actually may discuss that
with uh we got our nba insider uh vinnie
goodwill uh making his usual friday
appearance later because you know i've
seen reports where simmons you know may
not show
uh for training camp if he's still on
the roster obviously it's an awkward
situation and i and i do wonder maybe a
resident texas fan could uh
you know could enlighten me even um
if you know just just if daryl moore is
playing this the right way because on
one hand it's like dude he's a depressed
asset
still
there's value in ben simmons don't get
me wrong i know what he does well we all
know what he does well he doesn't do
well but he's a depressed asset mainly
because everybody knows it's not
realistic for him to return under
circumstances
um
i get one high value for him i also get
holding out to wait for
damian lillard's seemingly inevitable
realization that okay
chelsea phillips ain't playing and
coaching and we ain't contending with
this team no matter how much i want to
give a shot
so i'm ready to be traded so it's like
if you're daryl murray do you continue
to hold out and really make it
uncomfortable and
you know awkward for training camp if
not longer
in the hope that ben simmons assuming
that damian lillard runs out of patience
or for that matter bradley beal
fascinating game daryl moore is playing
so let me let me just flip it though on
its uh on the other way michael smith if
you're damien lillard uh as you say the
inevitable
will
uh dawn upon him that billups is not
suiting up
um unless he's suiting and booting um
and so
so
why
would you choose the sixers if you're
lillard you finally force your exit you
finally you know exert whatever you can
exert uh to leave the town that you you
really want to stay in um
by all intents and purposes would you
choose the sixers as your your your
landing spot
i think they're as good as anybody else
look i think one thing damien lillard
does not have to worry about at this
point because he's built up so much
respect and goodwill and credibility you
know throughout the nba community or and
for that matter the fans if he's even
worried about that he doesn't have to
worry about perception and not to worry
about image and underwear about legacy
he's fought the good fight he's run the
race in portland
um nobody's gonna say oh you're going
and joining such and such as team if he
does it i don't think so
um i think he's just got too much
goodwill built up so
out of any team if i got opportunity to
have joel embiid as my big man and the
way the sixers
uh depending on what they give up
you know would be able to defend which
is you know something that a very
foreign damien lillard is teams in
portland
i like them better than new york sorry i
know that stings no it does not michael
as a matter of fact i despise dolan and
and uh and as much as i enjoy
uh the coach and everybody who they put
together i think the the owner's
unworthy of it so you can keep on
keeping on with it yeah i mean it is
sexy this is for a superstar
you know a bona fide superstar like i
like what the nexus have done in a short
period of time the texas is for a bona
fide superstar to finally choose the
knicks um and and obviously it would be
his team and you know if he could have
it have his cake and needed to go to a
better team that that would obviously be
built around him
um you know if he goes to philly
you know on certain nights if not most
nights he's the second best player on
the team
uh but nonetheless i i think that's a
that's the one way to take it to the nba
final if you go to philly well i mean
michael smith brother from another top
of the hour here on peacock uh right now
on the rich eisen show
it this is amazing this is fascinating
to me because this is in the ether and
you know obviously i'm going to get lost
in the the start of football season but
this is going to have to come to a head
and obviously if simmons is untenable in
philadelphia and lillard does want out
in portland
um then that does seem to be a match let
me let me just throw a an actual
figurative match into this if you're the
bucks would you try to figure out a way
to get lillard just to shock everybody
and know that you've got to load up like
this year all well and good terrific it
was great giannis did what he did
but why don't you try and get in the
super team game with all due respect to
the guys that are there right now not
technically hey what's up with that no
you know but the nets are going to have
three
you know hall of famers coming back all
healthy no i know middleton did protect
did terrific and and holiday was great
and it worked
but yeah you know there is there is the
the the idea that durant is wearing a
shoe too large for his foot and that
might have made things different oh you
know all the time you know what i mean i
said all the time going back and forth
with holly about about because you know
i was i was pulling for the next pull up
for the bucks really just because we
were rooting against each other we don't
have dogs in that fight we just you know
hurt each other like that no but i i
like um
i like it where your head is in terms of
not resting on it sounds like just hey
you don't rest on your laurels don't
take anything for granted next new year
yes you won a championship you got a big
three if not a super team of your own
with
but the nets are going to come back with
reinforcements and patty mills
um you know the heat or you know
whatever replenish um you know
who knows what the sixers do so i i hear
you
uh i don't know that i would
i don't know that i would mess with a
good thing though because
i would look at it as okay in a in a
fantasy basketball perspective
what i want lillard sure
would that work from a chemistry
standpoint what would i have to give up
you know i'm obviously sacrificing
defensively by getting loaded as much as
i love his offensive game so if i'm
milwaukee lillard's not the guy but also
i'm running it back thinking okay
you know last year as the playoffs went
on giannis got better and giannis ended
up coming into his own and imagine a
second year
of giannis
playing with through holiday
uh given how they evolved how mike
boonholzer even started to evolve
and say and save this job in the process
by switching more on defense for example
um
yeah if i'm milwaukee i stand pat
and and i don't look at it as though hey
i got you know i was fortunate that ben
simmons passed up a layup where i was
fortunate that kevin durant
you know she was a size too big and he
wore down in overtime at game seven i
look at it as like hey we're just
getting started i hope so too but i do
like your thought about that because
you're right no no here's the deal
michael smith i look out here in los
angeles and lebron and anthony davis
could rest right or and
and uh you know the lakers can can rest
on
on everything and then they go at
russell westbrook right and at some
point you know the clippers are going to
have to figure out how to continue
adding there's it's in arms race here
and if lillard is available you know
those clubs though i i don't see the
flaws with milwaukee that would
necessitate
uh a earth shattering move like it would
take to get a damien or another
superstar player i mean not to mention i
don't even know what assets they have
left given all they gave up to give up
true holiday let's not forget that part
of it they gave up a bunch of picks for
that um in that move
um or
not even mention in the cap but i i get
what you're saying about the arms race
part but the difference i would say with
the lakers and for that matter the
clippers is you know those teams have
flaws it wasn't just lebron james's
injury
that undid the lakers last year they had
some roster construction flaws that they
needed to fix i don't know that they
necessarily fix them as much as they
made them different
because i mean when lebron was hurt and
or resting you know they got the brake
speed off them uh in theory westbrook
would uh mitigate some of that
westbrook on the floor with lebron
anthony davis doesn't seem to be the
right compliment but that's up to frank
vogel and lebron to figure out i i tend
to think they will
you know not to go too far down the
rabbit hole with the lakers only because
you know we've seen a couple of times
with lebron where it's like ah he's
redundant with dwyane wade or how's it
going to coexist
with kyrie irving they're both ball
dominant they said the other they
figured it out but the difference is
both those two guys irving more than
wade could actually shoot
uh and westbrook for all he does well he
does not do that well and lebron and
anthony davis don't need to be
surrounded by as much spacing as
shooting and shooting as possible before
i send you off to your show sir or you
have to run from this show to do yours
michael smith i i'm curious what you
thought of the
draymond exchange with kevin durant
on on his podcast chips which by the way
i thought
you know draymond has got the chops he's
got a career in broadcasting when right
not if not not if but when he wants it
right and and i don't blame him for
making that fodder for a podcast because
that is that is a great guest and a
great question to ask that guest and it
is a great shareable answer for your
podcast and all of that
um and he might not have thought about
what ramifications might come from it
once his guest leaves that at the
doorstep of his current coach and
general manager right um
but i'm i'm wondering what you thought
of the answer um and
not just the ramifications but the
answer itself from durant
about why uh about whether the set two
between the two led to durant's
departure
um
in a word i thought it was mine
generally i enjoy the conversation and i
really enjoyed it as it went on see like
that exchange and they covered that
previously but that exchange you know
made a lot of headlines and you know it
you know got a lot of engagement and on
the internet what have you
but i thought it got really good when
they talked about
really what makes them tick
uh you know durant even on personal
level not having children
um you know those things um
you know talk about when it was up all
the guys that go too far just what
drives them those things were way more
fascinating and i agree with you i mean
i looked at that and i looked at it with
such envy i was like yeah
i mean how come draymond green can do my
job
infinitely better than i can do here
that ain't fair
it was like i was like come on man like
you know you're already a hall of famer
you got to come you know take it here
but no all but all seriousness i just
looked at it as like guys like you know
you can say what you want about how the
organizational organization handle it
y'all two grown ass men like if y'all
wanted to squash it y'all could have
squashed it it doesn't doesn't matter
whether they disciplined draymond green
and made it weird like kevin durant
probably already had in his mind he was
gonna move on
and that didn't happen in a vacuum that
wasn't some isolated incident there was
a build up to that
um built up to that moment
and it came through ahead
and they didn't fix it
and kevin durant moved on but to now
pull bob myers and steve kerr even if
there's some truth to it and they're
entitled to their truth
you know one thing can be true and if
two adults wanted to squash it and put
it behind them kevin durant wanted to
stay he would have
so i i i thought i thought it was a
pretty
you know empty uh excuse uh if that
makes sense michael uh appreciate the
chat let's do it let's do it let's do
more of it um who else is on your
shoulder you're coming by
uh
you know going through once the football
season you're gonna start coming kicking
with us right you you reach out to me
you know my number you know how to get
me sure i do i can slide in your dm
you know not like jay crowder though
okay
okay for sure
you didn't expect that answer did your
tj almost spat out his coffee there he
goes
that's good that's good you quick on
your feet rich
take care of yourself michael smith
let's do it again soon brother brother
another top of the hour right here on
nbc sports on peacock hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here